habituellement le marché algérois est
bondée de monde
à quelques jours de l'aïd un fatal mais
le co vie 19 est passée par là les
traditionnels préparatifs de la fête
sont moins visibles et c'est sans réelle
en train que l'on fait ses courses mais
que dieu me pardonne cette année là il
n'a pas debout
ce n'est pas comme avant quand nous
avions de longues soirées pour nous
préparer à macao maintenant il ne se
passe rien fait depuis cette maladie
mandaté rien ne va plus en algèbre c'est
ce que voulait me faire vieux c'est un
problème mondial
elles sont ça rien que chez nous il faut
être patient et surtout gardons nos
enfants à la maison et armons nous
passions il n'y a rien à faire d'autre
nous aurions voulu que l'aide se passe
autrement que nous nous rassemblions en
famille et pourquoi pas voyagé mais non
cette fête est traditionnellement un
moment où les familles rendent visite à
plusieurs de leurs proches
mais depuis le mois de mars les trains
les taxis et les transports en commun
sont à l'arrêt en algérie les écoles les
mosquées les cafés restaurants ou encore
les magasins de vêtements sont aussi
fermés une ambiance bien morose pour
certains épiciers à cause du courant
navires us l'aïd va être très
particulier cette année nous sommes
obligés de suivre les instructions de
l'êta et attendre que ça passe et que
cette maladie nous qui en temps normal
cette période est caractérisé par
l'arrivée des algériens sur les
boutiques de prêt à porter pour se faire
beau à l'occasion de l'aïd
les consommateurs ont donc dû s'adapter
à la crise sanitaire et faire leurs
achats sur la toile
de la même manière que nous avons passé
le ramadan nous passerons l'aïd sans
rencontrer nos amis et nos familles et
comme les magasins sont fermés
nous achetons sur internet se mettre sur
son 31 et avoir une coupe impeccable
certains coiffeurs rendre service et
reçoivent les clients à leur domicile
c'est vrai qu'avec le confinement on ne
travaille plus notamment après
l'obligation de fermer boutique
mais en même temps où les coiffeurs on
veut faciliter les choses pour nos
clients surtout en ces périodes de fin
de ramadan et de l'oeil les gens doivent
être bien coiffée mais il faut savoir
que nous n'avons pas les mêmes
conditions plus dans nos salons mais on
fait avec
avec une accélération du nombre de
contaminations au courant des virus
pendant le ramadan les autorités ont
pris d'autres mesures pour l'aïd
les algériens ont l'interdiction de se
déplacer en voiture ce dimanche et ce
lundi le couvre feu lui a été durcie et
s'étend de 13 heures à 7 heures du matin
quand les capitales les autorités
locales ont explicitement demandé aux
habitants d'éviter les regroupements
familiaux et les contacts sociaux